شاب صيني عندما تتحدث اليه لن تشك للحظات
بانه ليس عربيا وخليجيا بتحديد احمد
الصيني كما يطلق عليه استضاع تحقيق الشهره
واسعه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه
على تطبيق تيك توك من خلال فيديوهات تظهر
واتقانه للغه العربيه وتحديدا اللهجه
الخليجيه يقدم محتوى ممتع ومتنوع من خلال
مشاركته اليوميه مع المتابعين ويدمج بين
الثقافه الصينيه والخليجيه حتى من خلال
الازياء في كثير من الاوقات كما شارك في
التمثيل في المسلسل الخليجي سكه سفر فما
سر حب وتعلق بالثقافه الخارجيه
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا المدون على منصه
تيك توكليه خليجي والملقب باحمد الصيني
احمد يسعد صباحك منور العربيه
شو يصير حبك
اللغه العربيه
اذا غلطت مره لا يمكن غلط مرت مرتين
فالحمد لله طولت الين ما تحسن لغتك طيب
احمد
احمد ليه الصين عندها سياسه الطفل الواحد
بس ما شاء الله عليه كسرت قواعد الصين
لك الحمد عندي سبع اطفال
فاكبرهم 33
واصغرهم سنه
كذلك
بالصدفه انا كنت دائما اسافر بين السعوديه
والامارات بحكم اشغالي وتعرفت على صديق
جدا
ما افكر في الزواج العينه هذاك الوقت كنت
اعزب همم
تكلم مع اخوانه واخوانه كانوا عارفين من
اهل البنت صار الزواج نصيب اللهم لك الحمد
لله اوكي
فرق جدا بسيط اول شيء العيون الكوريين
لتحت
اليابانيين لفوق
اما الصينيين قدامك
ومن طول يقولون ان الكوريين اطول من
اليابانيين واليابانيين اطول من الصين بس
انا 180 سم يعني طويل كيف كذا الصينيين
قصار
[موسيقى]
اذا بدك الفرق
الشعوب بتشوفنا كمان احنا متشابهين زي ما
نشوفهم متشابهه طيب عمرك احمد ليه هيك
يعني مش استغليت يعني شوي استفدت من شكلك
الاسياوي انك همم يعني تشعر اللي قدامك
انك ما بتفهم عربي
فنانين ومشاهير
اوريو
يا شباب انا اغانيه واصله الصين
ههه نشوف مشاركه في مسلسل سكه سفر ونقدر
[موسيقى]
اصبر شويه تشوفهم
جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
هل هو لذيذ
جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
طيب كان تمثيلك ناجح وملفت في مسلسل سكر
ثبتنا اكثر عن تجربه وتفكر تعيدها تبخير
يعني كانت احلى التجارب مريت فيها المخرج
المبدع اوس الشرقي قال لي تعال وين الحمد
لله اللهم لك الحمد يعني ما كان في ريشود
ريشوت على طول
ان شاء الله
لسه كمان خليجي بتعرف تغني خليجي وتغني
لنا هلا مباشره
[موسيقى]
اه جلسه مع الاهل طبعا ما هي متعوده على
الاكلات الصينيه
في بدايه الامر اوه لا لا لا لا لا
شوي شوي الحين خلاص
مهو وصل اكل صيني اكثر من السعودي
قال لها كلهم
واحنا كمان
طب اليوم كمان انا بس بدي احكي انه خالد
ليه بشعر
صيني والقلب خليجي
كيف اختارته
بالصدفه قبل سنه ونص قلت شو اسهل اسم صيني
فاخترت بروسلي
وبعدين
خليجي
القرار الجديد انا انزل 20 كيلو باذن الله
ليه 20 كيلو ههه
فيكم شعورك بالتفاعل تفاعل الناس خارجين
والعرب معك انا حتى ما كتبت اتوقع
يعني انا اعتبر طفل في السوشيال ميديا سنه
ونصف بس الحمد لله الاقبال كان ممتاز اااه
وان شاء الله نجتهد اكثر واكثر ونحسن
المحتوى باذن الله
صباح العرب
الجميله وان شاء الله نكررها مره ثانيه
يوم نضعف 20 كيلو
احنا هنشكرك جزيل الشكر
المدون على منصه التيك توك لخليجي احمد
الصغير